Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome back to Super Mario Maker.
Things are going better.
I mean, I said that in the last one
and you know sometimes
sometimes things don't go better
but this time they went better, so
let's hope that that streak continues
and that everything is gooders
doingness than what I've had in the past
Yes! I'm so good at this particular level
because I've done it one time before
and that's good enough for me.
Eat chode!
Assbag!
Come this way, do me a favor, blast those.
Get out of the way then.
Oh shit!
OH SHIT!!!
Okay, everything fine, everything good, I trust, goddamnit.
Shouldnt've trusted that much.
At least I'm not drunk anymore
Alright, get through this, do this, do that thing, do this thing,
Get this thing.
Chica, what are you do-
Chica! Are you on the sock again?
You leave that sock alone!
That's my sock, you do not chew on socks.
You have pre- you have your own toys!
Why do you need socks?
Chica is nuts...
Ah!
Goddammit!
What am I doing?
Aw shit, that's all bad.
But that's a Yosh!
That's a Yosh.
Yes,
YES!!!
Ya-
NOOOOOO
YOSH!!!
Well that was short lived.
Sure glad that that happened.
Aw my face.
Fricken-
A-hole.
Kay,
I need these!
I actually do!
OK
TRUSTING!
AHH
OHH
That was CLUTCH!
That was right on the edge!
The edge of success.
Okay.
Here we go.
HA-okay.
Everything's fine.
OH I can go down it?!
Is that good?
What is this?
What uz you?
*Gasp*
Perfect!
Yes, I don't know what this is going to be for but I'm gonna use it to the best of my ability!
ooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooo
Tell me it does somethin' gooood!
Oh,
This is not what I expected.
Dammit!
Ah, it's all out
damn-bah
Gawddammit!
That was gonna be something cool...
Oh?
Oh...
Oh!
I can just go down there.
Duh.
aaaaaaaAAAHHHHHHH
DON'T DO THAT!
Don't do that to me, not when I have to get through this!
Not when it's a long ass game
long ass level
with long ass problems
ah
#LONGASSPROBLEMS
All right, here we go... this one's gonna win it.
Okay... woop.... shwoop! Ah! Na-Na-Na-Na NooooooOOO!
Oh God damn it.
How did I fuck that up?
HOW? How did I fuck that up? I'll answer- I didn't jump properly, is the proper answer to what that happened there.
If it wasn't for--Chica! Stop messing with everything!!
Chica! Stop!
*from off-camera* Hey! Do NOT! That's bad, girl! You go lay down! You lay down! You lay down! Stay!
I have to put on the Dad Pants™  every once in awhile with Chica.
You stay! You stay there! You stay right there!
Good. STAY.
Don't give me that look.
You stay.
Okay, Chica's fine, she's fine. Everything's okay!
You gotta... You gotta be-- AWSHIT
shitbags
I gotta be the, you know, the discipline,
Bringing on the hammer of Thor every once in awhile.
Hoop! Hop!
And there we go-- got it.
Easy-Peasy because there is no problem...? There is no problem.
Eat Chode! Get here, do this thing.
Do for me... please do it for me.
Chica I told you to lay down what are you doing here? I said go lay down.
Where are you right now? You need to be laying down in your bed....
I've got a show to do!
You are not helping!
As far as I know you're not helping...?
I don't know, maybe she's helping-- AHH
I almost forgot, almost forgot.
Woooo, that was a little too close.
Okay.. the cool thing is, there is a Yosh' right here!
And I'm gonna blast you into next Tuesday.
You eat that... shoot that out there... Get that done... Dodge it on the way back...
Woah shit, oh shit, Come back Yosh'! Get that Ba-Bomb.
Aw shit stop this! Stop this craziness!
Just go down! Sorry Yosh'!
I meant to come back for you but I guess I'll do it next time!
Woop! Okay, I've gotten good at the precise jumps-- Chica go lay down.
Chica, no no nono no no no no!
Okay, go straight into... there we go.
That's better.
Okay, Wooooooo-okay.
Oh God, it's weird with the twirly jumps.
Okay... got that... okay.
So the trick is... woah--Not to go down there at all!
I thought I needed to go down there-- Why did I even think I needed to go down there? I OBVIOUSLY didn't need to go down there.
AHHHH it's Death! It's Death! It's Death! It's Death!
It's death... Hello sir, how are you doing?
Aw, God Damn it.
Why's it gotta be like this?
Why do you gotta put me on one last-- *gasp* I need that!
Give, give to me! Give to me! Thank you!
Okay, at least I'll be safe from damage
And maybe safe from something *gross wretching*
Don't roast my nuggets!
Okay.
Where's this gonna go? How's it gonna fuck me?
It's gonna fuck me like THIS. Ech.
I probably needed that. Did I needed that?
I don't know if I needed that.
Don't- don't- don't you- Don't you
Don't- Don't you!
Oh God, this ain't gonna be good, is it?
I'm just gonna, just gonna stay here. Everything's cool, everything's 100% cool.
Everything's cool-- woop!
Okay that ain't cool.
Just gonna... go over here now.
Uh huh, Uh huh, cool.
Yeah, totally fine...
You do your thing.
Don't come... No no no no--
don't do that (x4)
It's okay cause there's a... oh... there's a flower in there somewhere.
Yeah!! Damage boosting to the best!
Okay
Did he die? Did he die?
*gasp* he died! NOPE he didn't die.
Maybe he died? I don't know. It seems like di-- Yes!
Yeah... What?! How are you back?!
Wha- That doesn't make any sense get outta here.
Get out here! Get outta here!
Yeah!!!
*extended, slightly maniacal, laughter*
*sing-songy* Burn you Bastard!
*more laughter*
I did it!
Okay..
Woo.
Doing good so far
Doing good.
I'm gonna make it to the end of the challenge, and I'm gonna make it there in good time.
(sure you are...)
I promise you that. I promise.
That was a tough one because it was so long.
;)
Anyway..
So now we got "Mystery house con--"
I don't like the sound of "mystery house confusion" because that just makes it sound like there's-- OH NO.
Second one.
Aw God.
I don't wanna do this.
I don't wanna do this if it's just gonna be random chance I don't wanna do it.
It's so douche-y.
There's a comment here:
"It's a secret to everybody" That's what the comment says? It's a secret to everybody, really?
That's incredibly helpful, thank you.
*groan of dismay and failure*
He he he, Well then, at least I know it's the top one.
But if I go past the top one and it's another series of choices, I'm just going to be...
I'm just going to be incredibly pissed.
Incredibly pissed.
Eugh, okay.
Let's try this...
Okay is there gonna be, gonna be... ugh! Ah! Ugh! Awww NOO NO NO, Oh!
I did good there in the thing..
Okay, eh! Eugh!
I think that's what it wanted me to do? Is that what it wanted me to do?
No, apparently not.
Ahhh, I'm gonna go for it--
Nope, that's, well....
AH SCREW THIS ONE.
I'm gonna go with a "screw this one" I'm gonna go with 100% "screw this one"
I'm gonna go with "screw that"
I know it's gonna be even douchier.
Oh God, it's gonna be so... One??
One??? Do I gotta-- oh Well SHIT I missed 'em all!
*screaming*
Okay, all right then.
Whoop!
It's all just spin jumping! This is perfect!
I like this so much!
I can't. What do I??
*Confused Markiplier noises*
*laughing*
How is this helpful?
I can't go through!
What are you saying??
Are they serious? I can't read the title, I can't know if there's a secret in there or not.
I?
Is
Is there?
Is there like..?
Is there a?
Is there a secret?
Is there a secret I'm supposed to get here?
Huh?
Is there a goddamn secret?
Anywhere here?
Chica's getting antsy, I think she needs to go outside.
What am I?
Yeah "wow" but..?
What am I supposed to DO?
What am I supposed to--?
You can't do this!
You can't do this to me.
I did the thing!
I did-- OH
Let me just clear the top... Just in case.
You never know.
Uh oh.
Well why did it give a bad noise then?
Why did it give bad-- woah, hello.
Okay... doesn't seem particularly hard.
Did that-- Ooh A Checkpoint!
I like Checkpoints!
Well good!
Okay, so now I'm actually doing it.
But... oh.
Ah, I'm supposed to be small there.
So I need to damage..
Okay
Then I need to... yeah, okay. I know what I need to do.
Oh God, Don't do that! Don't do that!
Do anything but that.
Okay, so I got this and I know I need this over here.... Probably.
For some reason--
Oh I can just run across that.
Ah didididididi
didididididididididididididididididi BOING
Shoop doop AHHH!
*more maniacal laughter* I got it.
I got it- I got it Chica!
Oh sorry!
I just bonked her right in the face!
I didn't know you were so close!
What a good bop, what a good boop!
What a good poopie! What a good Poopy Butt!
What a good poop-a-loop!
[Talking to Chica] Who's a Bunka-Bussie-boo
[More Puppy Talk] Who's a teega-beega-buggy-bow
[So much puppy talk] Who's a Bunky Bow
She's good, She's good.
Okay, one more. We can do this, we can do this!
I don't know who I'm trying to convince, but we can do this.
Chica, don't, Chica, no, come on, Chica Leave it!
Leave it!
Good. Good girl, good girl.
Oh God, that sounds bad. Ahhh!
Oh okay I thought... I was very scared.
Oh shit.
I didn't realize there was a spike there, it was being blocked by all the numbers and such.
Okay... "Survival Simulator"
I don't like the sound of that.
Maybe it's like- they seem dangerous but they actually aren't?
One can hope. One can truly hope.
Well this isn't going to last long.
Okay, so..
I see... I see.
Oh God... Oh Gersh.
*In a Midwest accent* Oh gersh I don't know...
*high-pitched screaming*
No, I didn't--
Okay..
cool.
I guess I could...
Oh, I could just go 'em one at a time, I didn't have to run all the way through.
That was a stupid move on my part.
That was just... that was just ignorance.
Hup!
I could have just easily NOT done any of that.
Is that like and item down there that I can use?
Probably.
okay.
Oooh, eugh, I forgot which one was which...
Why do I need to go through this?
Why do I need to do this?
Maybe there's another way around this that's not so douche-y.
Maybe-
Maybe there's like... you know... a... Something in that block?
...one could hope.
One might hope.
Ones not gonna hold much hope... Ah!
Oh I...
I could just go the other way around. Why am I doing that? I could just go the other way around.
I can go up and above and around
And I can go up and above and around
But I'm not gonna go up and above and around because I'm so stupid.
That I'm not gonna do that.
Like this... easy peasy.
Okay? Well. This was not worth it.
This was easily not worth it.
Woah, hello.
You, can you?
*karate-esque yelps*
Oh God!
Not where I'm supposed to be but I can get around that!
I don't know if there's a point to that but I'm gonna get around that.
I can do that, I can do that, I can do that, I can do that
I can do that, easily.
*says sexily* Easy-Peasy lemon squeeze me
Okay.
Hup!
No you don't!
No you don't! No you don't!
What's over here! Ahh-- it looks like death!
Ooh, hello!
This looks cool--- ahh!
Aw, stupid wiggler, got in my way.
Okay, so there's no point in going over there. So I'm gonna go the other way around.
All right.
Uno mas.
Hoop!
Lets go the way we're "supposedly" suppose to go.
With the party music a-banging.
...and a-blasting.
GOD DAMN IT FUCK ME IN THE BUTTHOLE
I'm sorry I didn't mean that, everybody. Just don't take that out of context, and don't put it in the context that I gave for you.
Just completely ignore the fact that any of that actually happened and we're just gonna move on with our lives.
Sound good? Sound good.
Shit, ugh.
You're not gonna get me this time.
I'm gonna take my time with this, and then I'm gonna go right down there...
Woo, that was close.
Hup- Ahh!
Okay, I got it! What good did that do me?
Well frick a duck... OHGOD!
No you didn't tell me that they were spinning!
What was I supposed to do after that?
Son of a Bitch!
How am I supposed to get the other one it doesn't make any... ugh.
Maybe if I just get the key first, and then go away I can go in one of these doors.
And then figure out what the hell I'm supposed to do later... much after the fact.
Yeah, lets just pretend like we know-- Fuck, right on my grundle!
Why on my grundle?
Why is there one down there? How am I supposed to get it down out of the pit?
This is a bunch of bullshit.
This is bullshit
It's bullshit
Oh I know, because I can only go over here once.
That thing is not going to be there.
Oh, no it'll be there. Trust me, it'll be there.
Trust me, oh I see, that's not good.
This is the opposite of what I call--- What? Oh Fuck your magic, ah screw this.
Okay, I'm done for this episode, this is a bunch of bullshit.
This is a bunch of stupid bullshit.
So, thank you everybody so much for watching.
I'll see you in another video of this one where I'm gonna finish up this challenge in NO TIME
Thanks again.
And as always, I will see you, in the next video...
Buh Bye!
COINS!!!
<3